many of the people in your organization
many of them have been doing the job the
way they've always been doing it for 5
years 10 years 15 years 20 years and now
we're going to say okay it's going to be
all different the fear is not from the
change the fear is from the
unfamiliarity the fear is that I know
how to do that really really well and I
fear that I don't know how to do that
and I will feel insecure I'll be off my
game I'll lose my credibility um and and
you just have to put yourself in their
shoes the the the the fear is being
humiliated you I don't understand the
jargon it's all new you know it's it's a
whole host of things so empathy is King
empathy is King and not assuming that
everybody knows and people come along
with new directions at different Paces
it's like getting into shape you know
everybody goes to the gym but some
people get into shape quicker than
others there's no rule it's just how it
works um and it's the same here some
people come along licky split and some
people are just a little slower the ones
that are potentially destructive are the
ones that are so afraid that they
actually put up barriers and become
obstreperous they actually they actually
resist the change to the point where
they're clinging onto the past so
desperately that they they may
accidentally sabotage themselves um and
those are the ones that we have to have
difficult conversations we sit down and
say I need to have a difficult
conversation with you I I I I get a
sense that you're struggling because
everything we're trying to do all you do
is say no and I understand it's
difficult but we got to talk about this
because the company is going in this
direction
and I want you to be a part of this but
I am patient so let and to have that
conversation privately with empathy that
someone can come clean and say I'm I'm
scared because then you can hold their
hand